ah j'ouvre tout de suite notre second
débat consacré au risque de feu de méga
feu cet été en France et dans les
prochaines années le réchauffement
climatique multiplie ces risques les
moitien de la sécurité civile en homme
en femme et en matériel sont-ils adaptés
à cette nouvelle donne en débat dans une
minute mais d'abord on retourne en
Gironde reportage là ou près de 30 000
hectares avec brûlé l'été dernier Cécile
sigsous s'est rendu à Biganos et à
belin-bélier pour voir comment les élus
et les propriétaires forestiers se
mobilisent pour que ça ne recommence pas
alors voilà ce qui reste de notre belle
forêt tout est détruit tout est calciné
les boissons
pratiquement tous
évacués et Bernard rablade ne réalise
toujours pas il y a un nom de
gigantesque brasier ont emporté un quart
de son exploitation face à ce paysage
lunaire le sylviculteur est amère faire
un nouveau pousser ses arbres
hérité de sa famille prendra 40 ans il
espère que les incendies auront moins
permis une prise de conscience
on s'était un petit peu endormi en
disant que bon j'avais pas eu
d'événements aussi important que ça mais
voilà la réalité nous a rattrapé donc
maintenant la prise de conscience il
faut l'accélérer il faut faire comme on
dit plus vite et plus fort il faut
vraiment que que tout le monde c'est
l'affaire de tous voilà la prévention
faire attention à la forêt c'est
l'affaire de tous pour prévenir les feux
à l'approche des fortes chaleurs cette
année les propriétaires forestiers de
Gironde comme Bernard vont être
réquisitionnés pour effectuer des
patrouilles l'été va s'annoncer vraiment
très chaud là on va
mettre en place des équipes de de
patrouille sur massif forestier pour
informer tout le public qui s'y trouve
il y a un risque prégnant et que qui va
falloir prendre des précautions le
département aussi reçu une aide de
l'État pour installer des caméras de
surveillance et aider les propriétaires
à réhabiliter les pistes dans les forêts
du temps l'avaient pas mal dégradé donc
on a remis en ordre on a remis en état
en totalité
la partie roulante de façon à permettre
ce cours de des pompiers
d'accéder le plus rapidement possible
sur des départs de feu dans la forêt une
vigilance accrue désormais nécessaire
pour Bernard on est obligé de monter
d'un cran on est obligé de
remettre un petit peu ce qu'on appelait
ce qu'on appelle toujours la culture du
feu qui est plus ou moins perdue qui a
été plus ou moins oubliée parce que ici
dans la région il y avait pas eu de
l'incendie de cette grande ampleur
contrairement sur la région PACA en
sud-est de la France où c'est régulier
ou malheureusement ça brûle assez
souvent voilà et bien nous nous sommes
pas à l'abri de grands incendies la
culture du feu est aussi revenue aux
abords des villes à Biganos quelques
kilomètres plus loin Bruno Laffont le
maire est désormais intransigeant avec
ses administrés sur leur obligation de
débroussailler là ici ça a été nettoyé
c'est à dire qu'ici on a sorti toute la
végétation toutes les espèces arbustives
qui pouvaient combustible important pour
le feu et là ça n'a pas été fait et ça
doit être fait dans les semaines à venir
et ce n'est pas facile pour le maire de
faire comprendre aux habitants cette
réglementation comme le veut la loi
Marie-Louise doit débroussailler le
terrain en face de sa maison même s'il
ne lui appartient pas elle va devoir
payer un élagueur 1000 euros
[Musique]
la somme qu'on va en avoir je vois pas
pourquoi on va les nettoyer chez un
propriétaire un terrain qui nous
appartient pas c'est complètement
aberrant la population il y a une
certaine réthétisante parce que la loi
est mal comprise vous imaginez j'habite
depuis un certain nombre d'années on m'a
jamais demandé de faire ça c'est parce
qu'à ses incendies là que le meurtre
d'un goût se réveille
et puis il y a ceux qui habitent ici
depuis des années et des années et qui
comprennent pas pourquoi ils ont obligés
d'aller nettoyer alors que c'est pour
leur propre bien la future loi discuter
au Parlement prévoit de relever les
amendes à l'encontre de ceux qui ne
respecteraient pas cet obligation pour
une ou la font lui va certainement
augmenter les impôts locaux pour que
l'ensemble des habitants de la ville y
participent la France est-elle entrée
dans l'air des mégafeux nos moyens
humains et matériels sont-ils adaptés on
en débat avec Françoise Vimeu bonsoir
vous êtes climatologue directrice de
recherche à l'Institut de Recherche pour
le Développement Anne-Catherine Loisier
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice
Union centriste de la Côte d'Or
gestionnaire de forêt et rapporteur de
la proposition de loi qui vise à
renforcer la prévention et la lutte
contre l'intensification et l'extension
du risque incendie loi qui a été votée
aujourd'hui au Sénat accueille également
Éric bocardy bonjour bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes porte-parole de la Fédération
nationale des sapeurs-pompiers le France
et Laetitia cruppa éditorialise
politique on va définir un peu des
choses que sont les méga feuts est-ce
que ça concerne la France ou pas mais
d'abord j'aurais quand même qu'on
réagisse à ce sujet à cette scène alors
moi je connaissais pas cet aspect de la
loi qui est quand même surprenante
Anne-Catherine Loisy est-ce que c'est
normal que cette que cette dame doivent
débourser 1000 euros pour débroussailler
un terrain qui est pas le sien alors
cette dame elle doit débroussailler un
périmètre
identifié de protection je dirais autour
de sa maison qui est de 50 mètres et si
en fait elle est pas propriétaire
au-delà des 50 mètres elle doit
effectivement s'assurer que c'est quand
même débroussaillé pour protéger sa
maison de la même manière le
propriétaire qui est en face qui n'a pas
de maison à qui on va dire il faudrait
débroussailler ton terrain parce qu'il y
a une maison à côté qu'il faut protéger
il pourrait se poser la même question
après je crois qu'il faut qu'il y ait
une prise de conscience vraiment de nos
concitoyens de la vulnérabilité
aujourd'hui de leurs habitations quand
elles sont entourées de végétation et
que les pompiers mais je pense que
diront beaucoup mieux que moi ne seront
pas en capacité en cas de gros incendie
de maître un véhicule incendie derrière
chaque habitation donc dans leur intérêt
il vaut mieux qu'il débroussaille aux
abords de leurs habitations après on
pourrait se poser la question d'une aide
en fonction de capacité voilà est-ce que
tous les Français ont les moyens de le
faire ou pas bon voilà nous l'avions
proposé au Sénat un crédit d'impôts
notamment pour la première le premier
débroussaillage qui peut être conséquent
et qui peut atteindre des sommes comme
celle qui viennent d'être évoquées nos
collègues députés n'ont pas jugé bon de
nous suivre mais nous reviendrons sur le
sujet
pourquoi c'est si important en quelques
mots le
débroussaillit on dit les deux
débroussaillage débroussaillement autour
parce que c'est du carburant pour le feu
quoi c'est ça non seulement c'est du
carburant et puis la maison on reste
quand même un lieu de protection des
familles un lieu de Protection de la Vie
et de tout un chacun mais ça reste aussi
vous savez l'année dernière on a souvent
employé le terme de défense de points
sensibles et en fait ce que l'on
qualifie nous de processus ce sont
toutes les types d'infrastructures que
ce soit du domaine privé comme les
maisons que ce soit aussi du domaine
public comme toute autre infrastructure
ou du domaine de l'entreprise et donc on
estime qu'aujourd'hui
augmente le risque c'est ça le
réchauffement augmente les risques oui
bien sûr il y a deux choses dans le
changement climatique d'abord vous avez
la température qui augmente et une
température qui augmente bien ça
exacerbe tous les processus
d'évaporation donc évaporation de l'eau
du sol et vapo transpiration de l'eau
dans la végétation donc vous avez à la
fois une végétation très sèche et un sol
très sec et ça évidemment on comprend
bien que ça facilite les départs et la
propagation des incendies et puis après
il y a le deuxième facteur c'est le
déficit de puits donc ça ça ne touche
pas forcément toutes les régions et
quand vous avez un déficit de pluie qui
vient s'associer à des températures
particulièrement élevées c'est vraiment
le cocktail je dirais sans être cynique
parfait et en 2022 le Haut Conseil pour
le climat vient de nous le dire
l'anomalie de température de l'année
c'est 2,9 degrés c'est un ovni
climatique c'est ce qu'on attend pour le
plus de
degré par rapport au début du 20e siècle
voilà et en fait c'est ce qu'on attend
pour l'horizon 2050 2060 donc c'est en
avant sur les prévisions on espère que
c'est un ovni climatique on espère qu'on
n'est pas trop en avant mais là on voit
qu'on a eu vraiment des températures
très élevées et surtout longtemps 33
jours de vagues de chaleur
Eric bocardi est-ce que on peut parler
en France de mégafeux ou pas alors cette
notion de mégafeu elle a tendance à être
un élément assez anxiogène sur les
bandeaux et assez spectaculaire et qui
est utilisé de manière très médiatique
on va dire simplement nous au niveau des
sapeurs-pompiers de France comme de
l'ensemble des pompiers dans le monde on
essaie de quand même limiter cette
notion de mégafeu à un véritable on va
dire phénomène qui est lié à trois
facteurs très forts c'est déjà d'une
part ces conséquences on va dire sur
directement la population ou toute
activité socio-économique est-ce que le
feu va avoir une conséquence sur
l'activité humaine ou l'activité d'une
entreprise de toute une un bassin
d'entreprise ou d'une ville le deuxième
point c'est est-ce que notre moyen de
lutte soit aujourd'hui suffisant ou dans
ce cas précis d'un mégafeux les moyens
seront il suffisants pour pouvoir lutter
et éviter de se faire déborder et le
troisième point c'est aussi le feu en
lui-même c'est-à-dire son intensité sa
manière de pouvoir progresser soit par
la vitesse de propagation sous soit la
manière tout simplement dont il va se
générer tout seul avec la formation
notamment de ce que l'on voit
régulièrement c'est la formation de
pyrocumulonimbus dans le ciel qui va
permettre à un moment donné d'avoir son
propre climat à l'intérieur du feu et
qui va le pousser tout seul vers l'avant
alors ça
[Musique]
grégoryan qui était entendu ici au Sénat
il y a un peu plus d'un an c'était le 15
juin 2022 à l'époque il était président
de la Fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers il décrivait là c'est
c'est feux hors normes qui dépassent
l'entendement ce sont ces mots
nous étions encore avant-hier dans le
Gard pour des feux qui dépassent
l'entendement alors qu'il y avait très
peu de vent quand je dis qu'il dépasse
l'entendement c'est qu'il dépasse les 1
hectare et qui forcément se retrouve sur
des 10 20 30 100 hectares très
rapidement et qui dépasse ce que
j'appelle les feux à taille humaine
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné ils
prennent une telle intensité une telle
intensité en matière de température que
vous l'avez entendu s'il n'y a pas de
séparation s'il n'y a pas de coupure de
végétation entre la forêt et les
éléments de lutte on ne peut pas aller
au contact pas tellement ils sont
puissants puissants et je pense que
notre collègue chercheur pourra vous
indiquer mais les puissances se situent
dans l'ordre des mégawatts c'est des
centrales nucléaires qui se déplacent
des centrales nucléaires qui se
déplacent ou est-ce que disait Grégoire
Alliot l'an dernier Anne-Catherine
Loisier je rappelle que vous êtes
gestionnaire de forêts est-ce que les
comment réagit un arbre quand il est en
manque d'eau ce dont on parlait à
l'instant et qu'un incendie déclare un
accélérateur d'incendie ça doit dépendre
des espèces j'imagine mais comment ça se
passe alors en fait les forestiers
observent déjà depuis plusieurs années
ce phénomène et avec des sécheresses
cumulées et donc ils ont vu les arbres
ça faiblir et certains dépérir
massivement et un autre facteur
d'accélération du feu qui est
effectivement les massifs très
dépérissants aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup des Vosges on parle beaucoup du
Jura même en ce moment les situations
est très inquiétante parce qu'en fait
vous vous retrouvez avec des arbres
morts donc qui n'ont plus l'humidité et
qu'il n'y a plus l'humidité sur la
parcelle pour essayer de prévenir un
petit peu un départ d'incendie donc il y
a tout un travail en fait de
sylviculture qui transparaît au travers
des propos de Monsieur Alliot et même
d'anticipation on le voit sur les coupes
on l'a vu beaucoup avec les coupes
tactiques mais l'enjeu nous dans notre
tactique
on parlerait mieux que moi mais
directement des interventions on procède
un effet tactique donc créer ce qu'on
appelle un contre-feu pour limiter
justement l'extension du sinistre en
créant volontairement un feu pour éviter
que le lier plus de combustible que cela
pour le feu afin d'éviter qu'il avance
et plus compliqué c'est plus compliqué
avec avec le réchauffement climatique
parce que les armes effectivement
l'idée c'est que c'est fait déjà par des
spécialistes en la matière qui
permettent justement en fonction du vent
en fonction de l'orientation du feu de
pouvoir allumer à tout instant un
incendie qui va créer une ligne de front
directement et lorsque le feu va venir
il va s'éteindre ou va ralentir sa
progression parce que justement il
n'aura plus de combustible il n'aura
plus à manger et donc à partir de là les
coupes tactiques effectivement ça permet
on va dire de défigurer quelque part un
petit peu les massifs forestiers mais
pour une meilleure protection pourquoi
je dis défiguré c'est parce que vous
savez dans le sud de la France nous
avons dans le sud-est on a une culture
de l'incendie feu de forêt qui est
suffisamment forte et conséquente au
regard des claques entre guillemets pour
reprendre les propos parfois de Grégory
allión suite justement à de nombreux
incendies dans les années 90 et dans les
au début des années 2000 qui ont permis
de comprendre les on va dire d'un
aménagement du territoire et donc en
l'occurrence de créer des pistes DFCI de
défense de forêt contre l'incendie en
l'occurrence de créer aussi des zones
pyro-résistantes vont permettre
justement de ralentir la progression des
incendies de mieux protéger les
sapeurs-pompiers et aussi la population
qui parfois est là en touriste et alors
ce qui se passe Françoise c'est que il
va peut-être falloir dupliquer
finalement cette expérience ce modèle
des des départements du du Sud et du
Sud-Est à des départements du nord de la
Bretagne enfin bon voilà il y a des il y
a des régions où on parlait pas beaucoup
pas souvent de feu de forêt l'été et ça
y est ils y sont confrontés on voit les
projections du risque incendie elle
remonte vers le nord de la France elle
s'était cantonnée plutôt au sud au
sud-est au Sud-Ouest on voit aujourd'hui
qu'il y a un risque qui qui apparaît
dans des régions où il n'était pas
inexistait pas alors je pense par
exemple au massif forestier autour
d'Orléans ou même dans le Jura ou en
Bretagne et ça c'est lié vraiment aux
températures qui augmentent et puis au
déficit depuis que l'on voit se dessiner
pour la période estivale dans les
projections climatiques c'est très clair
sur tout le territoire donc en fait
c'est tout le territoire qui s'assèche
avec bien sûr un déficit plus prononcé
sur le pourtour méditerranéen et bien
sûr ce déficit de pluie il est associé
au degré de réchauffement je voudrais
juste repiquer parce que je pense qu'il
le terme dupliquer n'est pas forcément
adapté puisqu'en fait il y a pas une
forêt toutes les forêts de l'Hexagone ne
ressemblent pas aux forêts de Gironde ou
du Sud et nous dans notre stratégie il y
a défini une stratégie
interministérielle avoir un cadre
d'action mais ensuite mobiliser les
acteurs des territoires ou à l'échelle
des 10 des départements des régions pour
qu'il y ait une une adaptation en fait
aider des réponses qui soient adaptées
en fonction des acteurs et ça c'est très
important alors justement on va en
parler de cette loi qui a été votée ce
jeudi au Sénat grâce à Tam traduit
rebonsoir Tam donc il y a eu d'abord une
proposition de loi et elle a été adoptée
je crois que c'était hier par
l'Assemblée nationale et aujourd'hui par
le Sénat de tout adoption effectivement
à l'unanimité ce matin au Sénat et donc
définitivement adopté par le Parlement
parce que vous l'avez dit les députés
ont hier donné leur feu vert alors que
propose ce texte bientôt d'abord toute
une stratégie nationale est territoriale
qui repose sur deux jambes d'une part le
renforcement de la prévention et d'autre
part le renforcement des outils de lutte
contre un risque de plus en plus intense
et le texte prévoit notamment de mesures
très grand public elle prévoit
d'interdire dans la loi de fumer dans
une forêt exposée à un risque incendie
et notez que le jet de mégot est
explicitement concerné par les causes
qui sont fonctionnables pénalement et
puis elles prévoient aussi de renforcer
vous en avez parlé les obligations de
débroussaillement avec une aggravation
de sanctions pénale et administratives
en cas de non respect alors si les
sénateurs et sénatrices sont adoptés ce
texte sont pas entièrement satisfaits et
oui parce que le nerf de la guerre ce
sont souvent les cordons de la bourse
voilà Bercy car les sénateurs
souhaitaient aller beaucoup plus loin
notamment sur la mise en place de
dispositifs fiscaux incitatifs qui ont
été retirés du le reste final qui n'ont
pas résisté à la réunion entre députés
et sénateurs en commission mixte
paritaire les sénateurs voulaient par
exemple que les collectivités et droit à
des réductions de cotisations patronales
lorsqu'elles mettent à disposition des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires qui sont
leurs employés et cela ne se retrouve
pas dans le texte final ce sont des je
cite considérations budgétaires courtes
ont dénoncé de nombreux sénateurs autre
abandons marquants le crédit d'impôt que
les sénateurs souhaitait pour ceux qui
s'acquitent de leurs obligations de
débroussaillement et alors
qu'aujourd'hui seulement 30% de ces
travaux sont faits en France ce sont des
travaux qui peuvent coûter cher on l'a
entendu aux particuliers qui donc ne le
font pas des sujets qui vont être sans
doute redébattus au Parlement à
l'automne prochain lors de l'examen des
projets de loi de finances est-ce qu'on
peut dire pour autant de femmes que ce
texte manque d'ambition c'est un texte
qui va moins loin que ce qu'avait
préconisé les sénateurs initialement le
rapport qui avait servi de base à tout
cela à ce texte avait été remis en août
2022 après un été
marqué en France on se rappelle tous par
les incendies gigantesques dans les
Cévennes les Bouches-du-Rhône mais aussi
la Bretagne ou encore bien sûr la
Gironde la gauche par exemple voulait un
plan de préservation des forêts
voulaient la raie de la monoculture avec
l'histoire du pain des Landes qui est
plus exposé aux incendies qui a sans
doute joué leur du feu de l'été dernier
du coup ce matin et bien le Sénat a voté
à l'unanimité mais chaque groupe
quasiment a eu un regret à parler de
texte inachevé d'occasion manquée de
vote à contrecoeur tandis que la planète
brûle est bien les par le matin ne
regarde plus ailleurs mais sans doute
que certains ne voient pas assez loin de
la formule de Jacques Chirac en son
temps merci beaucoup il y a un élément
sur lequel je voudrais vous entendre
Eric bocardi sur le le fait que les les
employeurs puissent mettre à disposition
les sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
pourquoi c'est majeur d'abord parce
qu'il y a une grande majorité de
volontaires dans le corps des
sapeurs-pompiers 80%
c'est presque 187000 sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires donc ce sont d'abord des
volontaires qui ont souvent un travail
et donc ça veut dire qu'en termes de
moyens humains vous êtes souvent bloqué
par ça aujourd'hui on est sur un sujet
de on va dire de crise de disponibilité
on travaille beaucoup sur la tractivité
en tant que tel pour s'engager en tant
que pompier volontaire il y a beaucoup
d'efforts qui sont faits par les
territoires justement pour engager le
volontariat vraiment vers vers quelque
chose de plus prégnant de plus fort mais
néanmoins aujourd'hui on est sur un
sujet de disponibilité parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le nerf de la
guerre d'avoir des sapeurs-pompiers qui
soient à tout moment déclencher et
libérer de leurs obligations
professionnelles en contrepartie
justement un remerciement alors ça a été
effectivement adopté dans cette loi au
travers justement de des charges de
cotisation patronales qui sont on va
dire compensés soit de 2500 soit jusqu'à
vers un plafond de 10000 euros sur
l'ensemble des pompiers donc ça fait en
gros près de 5 sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires à libérer par structure donc
je pense que déjà dans un premier temps
dans le domaine privé parce que cela
concerne le domaine privé on est déjà
sur une première phase néanmoins on est
tout à fait d'accord aujourd'hui pour
effectivement reprendre les propos qui
ont été dit tout à l'heure d'aller un
peu plus loin parce qu'on sait pertinent
ce qu'il va falloir beaucoup plus de
pompiers
aujourd'hui un des plus gros employeurs
de sapeur-pompiers volontaire ce sont
les collectivités territoriales et
locales et je vous rappelle aussi une
chose c'est que je fais le lien
aujourd'hui avec ce qui se passe sur
l'ensemble du territoire national août
2022 le feu de Voreppe en Isère personne
ne connaissait vos reps on apprend
aujourd'hui le nom de ville ou village
parce qu'il y a des incendies dans ces
milieux là et c'est là où en première
réaction et intention on va solliciter
le volontariat et le volontariat dans ce
genre de situation géographique c'est la
première ressource essentielle et le
lien indéfectible avec les élus les
collectivités territoriales doivent se
retrouver justement dans le fait
d'étendre cet appel au collectivité
territorial je libère un peu les
pompiers
locales comme d'ailleurs les salariés
privés d'un territoire ils connaissent
le territoire ils connaissent bien et
quand il faut intervenir en cas
d'incendie dans l'urgence c'est quand
même un élément majeur après je voudrais
dire simplement c'est que déjà les
collectivités territoriales mettent
majoritairement en fait elles sont très
nombreuses à signer mais conventions en
fait avec les 10 où elles mettent à
disposition leur propre leur salarié ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
avez un employé dans vos services
techniques aux affaires sociales qui
d'un coup va partir et va aller en
intervention donc le service public sera
suspendu donc c'est une charge en fait
très importante aujourd'hui pour les
collectivités et nous notre démarche
elle était déjà de soutenir l'effort qui
est déjà réalisé aujourd'hui il y a déjà
beaucoup de collectivités mais elles le
font alors à plein enfin à leur coup
entier et demain compte tenu de la
situation des collectivités on peut en
voir on peut on peut être confronté à
certaines collectivités disent moi je
vais plus pouvoir signer la convention
de mise à disposition
un autre aspect de la loi thème en a
parlé c'est le plus médiatique cette
interdiction de fumer dans une forêt
exposée au risque incendie bon ça peut
sembler du bon sens que sauf que
manifestement il y a besoin d'une loi
pour faire passer le message comment ça
va se passer sur les préfectures qui
vont désigner les zones concernées c'est
quoi aujourd'hui qui se fait avec les
commissions de sécurité dans les
départements pour établir les massifs à
risque et les communes forestières par
exemple sont aussi mobilisées pour
mettre des affichages de manière à ce
que une personne un touriste qui arrive
à l'affichage ça suffit
il y a plein de dispositifs le
dispositif on est en train de
transformer la parole politique et les
enjeux politiques avec des actions
pragmatiques à deux jours du Tour de
France où on va distribuer près de 1,5
millions de cendrier de poche pourquoi
parce que le cendrier de poche est un
symbole au travers du mégot ça fait
partie aujourd'hui des enjeux d'un acte
de négligence aujourd'hui que l'on doit
résoudre pour éviter l'extension du
nombre de d'incendies pourquoi on fait
cela c'est déjà pour répondre à une
mesure extrêmement symbolique et vous
l'avez très bien souligné deuxièmement
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui on a plus on
Verdier les moyens de pouvoir prévenir
face à ce risque là hormis de distribuer
de prendre en compte ce type d'objet
parce qu'aujourd'hui dans les voitures
vous avez plus de cendrier aujourd'hui
quand vous voyez des gens fumés dans la
rue il faut pas stigmatiser que sur les
fumeurs mais il y a des gestes
aujourd'hui qui va falloir modifier au
même titre qu'aujourd'hui quand on jette
une poubelle dans une poubelle en
plastique une bouteille il est clair
qu'on fait un acte ou on a un sens
particulier parce qu'on fait le tri dans
une responsabilité écologique qui est
forte à notre niveau à nous donc il est
évident qu'aujourd'hui face à ces enjeux
là il est évident de répondre et le Tour
de France aujourd'hui va être une fête
populaire la fédération nationale met en
place un autocar avec un programme dédié
pour les comportements qui sauvent donc
on essaie de répondre par rapport à cela
de l'information de la pédagogie
aussi sur le sujet donc on est vraiment
on est vraiment en phase là dessus mais
pour y avoir des sanctions si quelqu'un
est pris en train de fumer
oui alors je pas non plus le désert mais
elle a été doublée et non c'est une
sanction importante mais ce que je
voulais dire c'est que là aussi dans les
départements les commissions de sécurité
ont un volet communication et pour
répondre à la question de Madame elles
adaptent tous les moyens du territoire
si c'est traversé par une autoroute
enfin voilà elles vont diffuser et
mettre en place un programme de
communication qui sera vraiment adapté
au territoire dans les moyens qui qui
sont bien qui existent déjà pour
anticiper les risques à la météo des
forêts c'est un nouveau dispositif qui
est né à la suite des incendies de l'été
dernier on va écouter tiens la
présentation vous parliez de Christophe
Béchu de présentation du ministre de la
transition écologique
l'enjeu c'est donc à partir du début du
mois de juin que tous les jours
les médias puissent avoir à disposition
une carte de météo des forêts en mettant
une carte tous les jours pour dire
attention l'humidité des sols la
sécheresse sur des vto sur des sur des
végétaux morts ou vivant le peu de pluie
de ces derniers jours la force des vents
font qu'on a un risque élevé ou très
élevé on pense que ça va contribuer à
faire en sorte que chacun soit attentif
et à mieux comprendre les décisions qui
pourront être prises localement par les
autorités pour interdire des balades en
forêt quand les risques sont trop élevés
Françoise il me est-ce qu'on peut déjà
évaluer juger l'intérêt de cette de
cette météo des forêts je crois qu'il y
a un intérêt absolument évident d'abord
c'est la sensibilisation et la pédagogie
s'est répétée tous les jours où tous les
deux jours donc si on a un bulletin
météo ou on explique qui d'abord qu'il y
a un risque et que ce risque est plus ou
moins fort avec ce code couleur qui est
vraiment intuitif et très compréhensif
bon moi je pense que il y a pas besoin
d'attendre pour savoir que c'est
efficace et après ça vient quand même
combler une grosse lacune que l'on a en
France qui ont Quié que de manière
générale on n'a pas la culture du risque
on nous apprend pas à réagir au risque
on nous apprend pas c'est quoi la
vulnérabilité et ça ça concerne pas que
les incendies je pense à tous les
événements extrêmes météorologiques qui
augmentent en fréquence et en intensité
avec le changement climatique ça peut
être des inondations on va pas chercher
sa voiture dans un parking en sous-sol
corps l'eau monte donc c'est toute cette
culture du risque qui à mon avis devrait
aussi être dans les écoles est-ce que
c'est lié aussi au fait qu'on est alors
je suis encore au présent je sais pas si
un pays tempéré
de climat tempérés et que finalement on
avait moins l'habitude que d'autres je
pense au pays par exemple États-Unis au
Canada des événements extrêmes quand il
y a une tempête de neige aux États-Unis
bah personne ne sort c'est c'est ça fait
des générations et personne va prendre
le risque de sortir en France on a
tendance à se dire parfois ah bah je
peux continuer à vivre comme si de la
planète votre avis là-dessus et je vous
donne la parole évidemment à l'exception
de nos outre-mer où on a un risque qui
peut être volcanique ou sismiques ça
c'est absolument évident et puis je
pense que jusqu'à l'été 2022 à peu près
tout le monde ne se sentait pas concerné
par les impacts du changement climatique
on n'avait pas bien compris que on était
aussi impactés de manière diverse et
variée et depuis l'été 2022 je trouve
quand même que les mentalités ont évolué
il y a plus de sensibilité à ce qui se
passe au niveau environnemental
on le ressent parce que effectivement
aujourd'hui c'est 35000 communes en
France c'est deux tiers de ces communes
qui sont au moins impactés par un risque
majeur donc c'est assez conséquent et on
voit aujourd'hui que le nombre de
risques naturels ont été multipliées par
5 en 15 ans donc en fait ils peuvent le
savoir mais on leur propose des outils
qui sont peut-être pas forcément adaptés
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a des dix
crimes tout ce genre de de moyens
aujourd'hui avec des acronymes qu'on
peut avoir accès directement sur
Internet les pompiers vous adorez les
acronymes on adore ça nous et tout le
monde adore ça mais le problème c'est
que vous voyez dans cette compréhension
là c'est difficile de le rendre acc
possible concitoyens et de prendre
l'environnement de et son enjeu en
termes de risque donc il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui la météo des forêts c'est
génial pourquoi parce que déjà un on
apprend son territoire 2 la semaine
dernière il y a 15 jours de cela quand
il y a eu un risque important dans les
Vosges 3 ou 4 appels médiatiques dans la
foulée pour me dire mais comment ça se
fait qu'il y a des risques modérés dans
les Vosges et ça on soit ouvert dans le
sud de la France gym il y avait ça on le
connaît depuis très longtemps chez nous
sauf que là aujourd'hui vous le
constatez donc il y a un sujet aussi qui
est donc qui est un enjeu c'est comment
on va pouvoir répondre sur l'ensemble du
territoire national à tous ces enjeux
face au risque et aujourd'hui le premier
maillon qui va permettre de nous aider à
faire lutter contre l'ensemble de ces
dérèglements climatiques c'est le
concitoyen en s'appropriant son
territoire et en mieux c'est du cas en
format je rappelle d'ailleurs que le 13
octobre c'est la journée de la
résilience et c'est pas pour rien que ça
a lieu c'est justement pour avoir des
réponses à une notion d'attitude et de
comportement face au danger et alors il
y a une question qui se pose c'est de
l'adaptation de nos moyens humains
ces nouveaux risques est-ce qu'il faut
par exemple créer un ministère de la
Sécurité civile on va en parler dans
dans un instant mais Laetitia on s'est
d'abord posé la question
d'identification de celui ou celle qui
porte ce dossier des des formes oui bah
écoutez je me suis la supposé toute
l'après-midi et je peux vous dire que
pour l'instant il n'y a pas une personne
un ministre dans le gouvernement qui
serait l'incarnation de ce combat contre
les feux ou les mégafeux alors pour
l'opérationnel vous le savez monsieur
bien sûr c'est Gérard Darmanin qui est
le référent des pompiers vont se battre
contre les feux et puis on l'oublie
souvent mais nous nous l'avons montré
sur Public Sénat il y a Christophe Béchu
qui est le ministre de la transition et
qui normalement se regarde vraiment tout
sa feuille de route je pense qu'il est
de façon cohérente en charge de ce
dossier mais c'est vrai qu'il est encore
très peu connu le déficit de notoriété
ça peut être un gros handicap en
politique et il est peu identifié sur
cette cause Christophe dans le
comportement de l'exécutif on peut dire
que tout le monde ne lui facilite pas la
tâche c'est ça et nous on a commencé par
le président de la
[Musique]
République combat contre les mégafeux et
par exemple il y a trois semaines
c'était début juin Emmanuel Macron était
en déplacement dans le Gard et c'est lui
qui a détaillé le dispositif de
prévention et les moyens humains et
matériels avant que nos débuts de la
saison estivale on l'écoute les moyens
je le disais nous on a beaucoup monté en
capacité ces dernières années mais ils
ont été encore renforcés pour l'été 2023
nous passons de 38 à 47 appareils
j'ai vu donc une partie des hélicoptères
qui depuis quelques jours sont
pleinement mobilisables
et que c'était une un des engagements de
l'été dernier et un centre de
coordination des moyens aériens a été
mis en place ici à Nîmes
et donc nous continuerons la montée en
puissance des moyens aériens alors
est-ce qu'on peut dire simplement c'est
le président qui se charge de ce dossier
des méga fruits mais non ce n'est pas
d'autres dossiers et donc c'est
difficile après de vraiment d'identifier
la personne qui va l'être mais par
exemple si Christophe Béchu n'est pas le
ministre qui prend en charge la
communication et toutes les
communications sur l'écologie on aurait
pu imaginer une Elizabeth borne je vous
rappelle qu'elle a quand même été nommée
à Matignon avec cette promesse volet
écologique et revenait à la première
ministre donc pourquoi pas une Elisabeth
borne sur le terrain en cas de
catastrophe climatique pour aussi les
communications des mesures prises contre
les feux finalement en voulant prendre
ce projet encore une fois ce dossier à
part le corps Emmanuel Macron
se rajoute un peu le travail et surtout
ne rend pas si clair que cela la
communication et le combat du
gouvernement contre ce problème est-ce
qu'il faut
Eric bocardi créer un ministère de la
Sécurité civile et si oui qu'est-ce que
ça changeait alors c'est vrai que depuis
tout à l'heure quand on débat sur le
thème de l'incendie mais largement le
dérèglement climatique avec derrière les
enjeux vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
le comportement à avoir lorsqu'il y a
des inondations je pense qu'on touche
différents domaines on touche
l'éducation on touche le risque et on
touche nécessairement aussi le climat
donc quand on touche ces trois spectres
assez intenses et assez piliers
aujourd'hui dans l'organisation on va
dire au sens large politique et du
gouvernement on se dit qu'effectivement
une place en lieu au plus près de la du
Premier ministre permettrait justement
d'être assez cohérent sur une politique
globale par rapport à ces enjeux je
pense que le niveau de on va dire de
d'intérêt qu'aujourd'hui les concitoyens
aussi tout le gouvernement et les
personnalités politiques sur les enjeux
n'est plus à démontrer il y a un
consensus il faut le dire quand on voit
aujourd'hui que au travers de la CMP il
y a quand même une certaine unanimité
j'adore les acronymes vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure mais sur la commission
mixte paritaire on voit qu'il y a quand
même une issue assez large c'est une
année il faut le reconnaître même si
effectivement on n'est pas allé voir
plus loin donc ça veut dire qu'il y a un
enjeu ok sur lesquels ça serait
aujourd'hui assez aisé et compréhensible
d'avoir justement une clé de voûte
nécessaire pour pouvoir engager des
réflexions à la fois dans l'éducation le
risque et la réponse Françoise votre ami
là-dessus sur finalement un ministère
dédié si je simplifie surtout si on se
projette à horizon 15 ou 20 ans non mais
c'est un ministère de l'adaptation au
changement climatique il faudrait c'est
ça en fait le mot clé c'est c'est
l'adaptation on sait qu'il faut mener en
parallèle à la fois l'atténuation de nos
émissions parce qu'on arrivera pas à
s'adapter à des degrés de réchauffement
qui vont dépasser 2 degrés en global
c'est-à-dire 3 degrés pour la France
hexagonale et l'adaptation alors le
rapport un duo conseil pour le climat
qui est sorti hier le dit on n'est pas
prêt l'année dernière on était en limite
on a mis tous les moyens sur les feux on
était en limite on y est arrivé juste
ça va pas s'arranger
bien sûr et ça va pas s'arranger et si
jamais il y a des méga feu en même temps
que dans une autre région il y a des
inondations terribles avec des orages et
des pluies torrentielles terrifiantes
dans le cadre justement fin août 2022
incendie juste derrière un volet de
tempête encore donc ça veut dire qu'on y
était sur une réponse polymorphe on va
dire en terme de gestion de crise
exactement et là l'adaptation elle doit
pas être réactive c'est-à-dire ça doit
pas être du coup par coup ça doit être
une adaptation transformative
structurelle Anne-Catherine Loisy est-ce
que dans la loi il est prévu aussi parce
qu'on a vu le dossier prévention qui est
très important est-ce qu'il est prévu
aussi des moyens supplémentaires
oui alors d'abord je voudrais quand même
permettre de répondre sur ce sujet qui
est forcément un sujet très politique et
qui a suscité beaucoup de débats moi je
pense qu'il faut bien savoir de quoi
parle je pense que le sujet de la
création d'un ministère de la gestion
des risques et des crises il s'impose de
plus en plus et à mon avis on va y
arriver après la stratégie d'adaptation
changement climatique elle touche aussi
d'autres secteurs voilà ça va être
l'agriculture la fin voilà nous dans
notre projet de loi on sollicite une
vraiment une stratégie
interministérielle parce que ça je pense
que c'est important en tout cas que les
ministères abordent les choses de
manière croisée sur les moyens oui il y
a d'abord alors déjà avec les moyens
actuels comment faciliter la gestion
donc il y a un certain nombre de
dispositif qui permette aux pompiers
voilà ça d'exonération il faut déjà
fluidifier l'existant et puis après se
projeter effectivement sur des des
moyens aériens mais on en a parlé tout à
l'heure des moyens humains moi je pense
que ce le vrai sujet aujourd'hui sont
des moyens parce que les avions ici à ma
connaissance il circulent pas la nuit
donc on a vraiment besoin de moyens
humains sur le terrain et et c'est là
dessus qu'il faut qu'on mette la
priorité à mon sens pour répondre aux
feux qui sont là et qui sont là toute
l'année maintenant qui sont là qui sont
là toute l'année qui sont là dans des
régions où ils étaient pas avant en
France aussi ce que ce qui vient d'être
évoqué c'est que on parle aujourd'hui du
risque et du dérèglement climatique et
derrière ces enjeux pour défendre les
territoires mais au quotidien les
sapeurs-pompiers c'est 80% des missions
de secours d'urgence aux personnes donc
cela veut dire que à côté de cela il y a
toujours les interventions du quotidien
qui passent sous écho radars mais qui
comme a été très justement souligné ont
besoin aujourd'hui d'être renforcé en
moyenne humain parce que les véhicules
seuls ne peuvent pas rouler donc il est
évident qu'aujourd'hui il va falloir en
même temps agir sur le domaine du
dérèglement climatique tout en
conservant notre capital aujourd'hui de
réponse et distribution des secours à
raison d'une intervention toutes les 7
secondes en France on va se projeter
dans dans l'avenir on disait horizon 15
20 ans écoutez cet ingénieur spécialisé
dans l'étude des forêts méditerranéennes
lui aussi était auditionné au Sénat
c'était au mois de juin dernier
s'appelle François piment bon c'est
plutôt pessimiste pour faire simple en
2050 on attend une augmentation des
surfaces brûlées sur la zone Sud-Est
d'environ 80%
et à la fin de siècle ça dépend
énormément des scénarios d'émissions qui
seront
suivis à l'échelle globale mais dans les
scénario pessimiste on serait sur un
triplement des activités de feu donc sur
les nombre de grands feux 200 hectares
et sur les surfaces brûlées donc avec
une accélération vraiment notable alors
que sous scénario
4.5 là de
réduction des émissions on serait sur
une stabilisation autour des + 80 % dont
j'ai parlé avant bon il y a beaucoup de
chiffres mais moi ce que je retiens
c'est attention si on fait rien il y a
une les surfaces brûlées dans le sud-est
ça va augmenter de 80%
c'est alors on va essayer d'être un peu
plus actif est-ce que c'est
une fatalité ou est-ce que il y a des
moyens d'éviter cette cette évolution
alors en fait on sait que jusqu'à 2040
le climat enfin le réchauffement il est
déterminé par nos activités passées on a
la main sur la deuxième moitié du 21e
siècle c'est-à-dire que on n'a pas trop
la main sur la température à horizon
2040 2050 en revanche on a la main sur
la température à horizon 2100 quand on
sait qu'en 2100 a priori avec les
trajectoires actuels que l'on suit en
termes d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre l'été 2022 sera un été froid sa
glace
donc là là je crois que il faut dire que
non seulement on a on a la main sur la
deuxième partie que on sait comment
faire c'est à dire qu'on a un problème
mais on l'a on l'a quand même bien
étudié et on connaît les solutions
secteur par secteur territoire par
territoire donc je trouve que la
considérer que ça va pas assez vite il y
a tout un débat politique
d'ailleurs là-dessus et sociétale
technique et scientifique les choses
mettent du temps à se mettre en place il
y a des adaptations qui ne peuvent pas
se mettre en place en quelques semaines
l'adaptation à la sécheresse pour le
secteur agricole c'est pas possible en
quelque semaines donc ça c'était c'est
de la technique bon
donc là je crois que c'est important de
rester optimiste de rester positif parce
que la situation est plutôt favorable
malgré tout mais on prend pas le chemin
qu'on devrait prendre pour limiter le
degré de réchauffement et encore une
fois rappeler que l'adaptation elle
devient complexe voire impossible dans
certains territoires pas uniquement pour
les incendies au-delà d'un certain degré
de réchauffement
vous parliez de de ce qu'on peut faire
si on se reconcentre là sur les forêts
par exemple on peut on peut planter de
nouvelles espèces variées il y a des
espèces qui sont plus résistantes plus
adaptées au réchauffement ça fait partie
des pistes alors d'abord je voudrais
dire que certes il faudrait voir plus
vulnérable mais le feu il prend rarement
tout seul donc on revient au débat qu'on
a eu tout à l'heure c'est la culture
pour plus de surveillance une plus
grande vigilance pour réagir rapidement
et éviter que le feu se propage donc
tout ça ce sont des outils qui sont à
nos mains et nous pouvons agir et après
effectivement il y a comment rendre les
massifs forestiers plus plus plus
résilients donc avec des choix d'essence
adaptés avec aussi des desserts pour y
aller plus rapidement donc tout ça ça
fait partie du travail qui menait avec
les chercheurs d'ailleurs les chercheurs
de l'INRA et autres pour pour acquérir
des connaissances parce qu'en fait on se
projette là dans un futur qu'on ne
connaît pas et donc quel type d'essence
on va pouvoir effectivement installer
comment on va aussi répondre aux besoins
de notre société en matériaux boire
parce que effectivement derrière tout ça
il y a un enjeu carbone et si on a plus
de matériaux bois ça posera d'autres
questions donc il faut concilier cette
multifonctionnalité de la de la forêt et
la rendre en même temps plus résiliente
mais nous avons nous avons des outils et
nous avons la nature est riche en France
nous avons plus de 190 200 essences et
parmi celles là il y en a qui seront
plus résilient justement je vous montre
là-dessus parce que on a pas du tout
parlé de ce qui s'est passé au Canada
mais quand même il faut en dire un mot
peut-être sur sur l'impact climatique
c'est à dire que c'est un puit de
carbone qui a brûlé quoi c'est il faut
il faut expliquer ça oui il y a deux
choses d'abord là aujourd'hui si on
regarde le dioxyde de carbone qui a été
émis par les incendies c'est 550
millions de tonnes donc pour qu'on
comprenne ce que ça veut dire 550
millions de tonnes c'est ce que le
Canada a émis en 2021 juste par la
combustion des énergies fossiles donc
c'est énorme alors c'est Amy brutalement
il peut y avoir un effet qui va venir
atténuer c'est-à-dire que si la forêt se
régénère elle va se régénérer petit à
petit et une forêt qui pousse c'est une
forêt qui absorbe beaucoup de carbone
parce que bah faut construire un tronc
des branches et des feuilles et donc on
peut avoir une sorte de compensation
mais c'est une compensation sur
plusieurs décennies donc c'est pas tout
à fait pareil et puis faut-il encore que
la forêt se régénère ça va dépendre du
type de forêt qui va se régénérer est-ce
que ça va être sur la même surface et ce
genre enfin ce genre de choses
on va terminer Éric bocardier en étant
précis sur les moyens puisque on se pose
la question de l'adaptation de de nos
moyens humains et matériel voilà cette
nouvelle donne des feux de forêts il y a
combien de
camions-citerne en France et il en
faudrait combien tiens par exemple vous
avez à peu près 3700 camion-citerne fête
forêt en France pour être cohérent
puisqu'on a affaire une annualisation et
une globalisation aujourd'hui des
incendies pour être cohérent il faudra
atteindre le palier 10000 parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est 3700 camions cités
de feu de forêt pour 60% et sont
concentrés dans le sud-est de la France
et dans le sud donc ça veut dire qu'il y
a tout l'ensemble du reste du territoire
national qui doit être équipé il y a un
mois et demi de cela je prends souvent
cet exemple à Haute-Saône venez d'être
équipé de son premier Canet de citerne
fête forêt on est à 87000
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires comme
professionnel formé au risque feu de
forêt
pas tous les sapeurs-pompiers jusqu'à
présent étaient formés donc on sait
qu'aujourd'hui l'École nationale
supérieure de sapeurs-pompiers que
dirige Grégory alliott aujourd'hui
l'entente de Valabre donc ce fameux
vecteur extrêmement important d'études
du feu de forêt et de formation des
cadres feux de forêts aujourd'hui étant
pleine demande et en pleine absorption
justement de stagiaires pour continuer à
renforcer l'ensemble des
sapeurs-pompiers de tous les
départements à la culture du risque feux
de forêt et ajustement la lutte contre
les incendies parce que c'est devenu un
enjeu prioritaire mais lorsque l'on est
juste c'est qu'aujourd'hui notre
capacité aujourd'hui de produire des
camions assistantes fête forêt elle doit
répondre à une logique française de
réponses territoriale mais aujourd'hui
ça doit répondre aussi à l'ensemble de
l'Europe puisqu'on a une culture et une
industrie française qui répond
aujourd'hui aux exigences et qui est
fait aujourd'hui demander dans les
autres pays européens merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je vous dis à bientôt sur sur
public c'est la voilà c'est la fin de ce
numéro de sens public vous pouvez
retrouver tous les programmes de la
chaîne sur notre plateforme public
sénat.fr c'est tout simple et pilot er
que demain Oriane Mancini dans la
matinale à 8h reçoit Henri Leclerc
l'avocat et président d'honneur de la
Ligue des droits de l'Homme bonne soirée
[Musique]